place knickers dans le monde c'est 80
milliards de dollars c'est énorme
[Musique]
c'est un énorme phénomène et qui se
vérifie dans les chiffres
ce qui pour la première fois en 2019 une
chaussure sur deux vendus en france
c'est une paire de baskets
les marques de luxe s'approprient cette
culture parce que c'est de plus en plus
vendeur et il faut savoir que la mode en
fait c'est un espèce de cycle 1 ça
commence dans la rue ça arrive sur les
sur les podiums des fashion et pour
revenir après à la rue
[Musique]
le marché des jeunes il a toujours été
important de tout temps il faut savoir
que c'est un des marchés les plus
profitables les gens n'y pense pas mais
les jeunes sont ceux qui ont le plus
grand pouvoir d'achat puisqu'ils n'ont
aucune charge et que des rentrées leur
argent de poche les étrennes etc
les touches et c'est évidemment
essentiel pour une période bien bien
merci je peux aller jusqu'à 1000 euros
je pense pas
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a le côté où on a les
baskets
on a ce qui est associé à m peut-être
l'univers de la musique univers donc du
hip hop du rap tout ce qui est stricte
culture le graff et c'est vraiment de
base
quelque chose pour être à l'aise
certains faire du sport mais ça c'était
vraiment à la base mais il ya très
longtemps